is so if I couldn't make it what makes
you think you could make it
what does it mean to you to be an artist
oh wow
uh
it means that I'm able to
to give something back to people and to
hopefully
Enlighten someone you know and and help
someone understand something whatever it
is I mean and plus me being an artist
is basically all I can do anyway so so I
mean that's just who I am you know and I
tell people I say if if you're going to
be an actor
you can't go into it wanting to become a
star you can't go into it and uh put a
time limit on it I mean years ago I knew
people that um
got into it and it was like saying
especially when they moved out here to
California they were like well if I
don't have a TV show by you know by in
another year I'm going back to Kansas
it's like uh okay you better go back to
Kansas
you can't put a time limit this is a
life this is this is a life you know
you're gonna have ups and downs you're
gonna have more Downs than UPS and I
find that people that and I can't say
and I don't want to say all people but I
find that a lot of people that
were stars in college or whatever as
actors in their universities
a lot of them tend to have a harder time
because they um
they've been spoiled to a certain point
and and once they get into the real
world of acting
they've realized they just one of the
numbers
and see By Me Not
majoring and being in college like this
as that it was easy for me to roll with
the punches on it I mean I did this as a
kid you know you know I did plays and I
all in the little stuff play piano all
that kind of stuff as a kid but I left
it and went into sports
so Heaven had a sports background I know
like that thing I said about you not
gonna win everything you know because in
sports you're not gonna win everything
so you turn you tend to have a little
more of an even Keel about it and I find
that a lot of my friends that in that I
went to college with that were like in
the theater department and had a
degree as a director in in film
are you know telemarketers and and
not in the business there's nothing
wrong with those jobs of course you know
but they tend not to make it like that
and it was funny because a lot of those
Folk
I came into it from somewhere else
I came into it you know uh just
basically from the sports and
being just a a loafer in college I hate
to say it but I wasn't really great in
college because I was like I got pretty
good grades towards the end but my first
couple of years I was like oh okay I was
clowning around and everything you know
and I didn't get serious until it was
time to get out of there you know but
but most people tend to you know
when they come from a theater background
or whatever
they tend to have a hard time because
they have a certain expectation and this
industry does not care
once you get in this business they don't
care I mean it's nice to have a a
masters from Yale you know drama school
I mean you might have a con it's all
connections and whatnot anyway so you
might be able to do some things but if
it's just based upon you know uh
have studied here at juilliards you know
and uh no no you got to get once you get
in front of that camera or get on that
stage you either have it or you don't
yeah I think early rejection actually
helps you because also too it's not just
um the degree but let's suppose you were
a big fish back in your little Pond or
you were the family star and everyone
you know thought you were oh we can't
wait to see little Joey go off and he's
gonna make it and then
I think that spoils people and yeah this
is not that kind of a town
it sets you up almost well yeah because
see you get spoiled because like you say
you were a big fish in a small pond now
you're a small fish in the biggest pond
so you know it all weighs out
differently you know so you have to
it it all depends on the type of person
you it all gets back to what type of
person you are
how you are inside it all gets back to
that and
um like I said I have friends that were
like really really really
top notch in school in this business
and and nowhere to be found
and uh matter of fact I ran into a guy
a few years back who I went to high
school with
who was the star of everything in high
school
and he said to me he says
wow I can't believe that you've been
doing this all these many years and and
I was the I was the top actor in high
school I'm like yeah you were
that's all I can say was yeah
you ran into him here in Los Angeles no
I ran into him back in Michigan you know
back home and he was like yeah I I said
yeah you yeah you really were good yeah
yeah you were excellent what makes
artists different than other people
well different in the sense of uh what
you do but not necessarily
you shouldn't be different as far as
the type of person you are it's the
difference is basically what you do
being an artist being and whether you're
a sculptor or a painter or a
a musician or actor or a dancer or
whatever
the only difference is what you do it
shouldn't be the type of person you are
see see where people have a problem in
our business is
once they get in it
they tend to uh not all people but some
people they tend to let it
overwhelm them as far as they're
sensitive who they are and how important
they are and my thing has always been
you just it's a job you know
because like I said I couldn't do
anything else I got fired
from every regular job I've ever had I
got fired from my paper route when I was
12. and it started a long list of being
fired from regular jobs
once I got in this
it was different and I got fired once in
this but I won't get into that but but
you know it's just you got to be you got
to be a regular person
and and I find that um
being a regular person
people in the industry like you for that
I don't have many people that don't like
me
because it's hard not to like me because
I'm just a regular guy I don't I'm not
pretentious to anything like that I
don't you know
well yes sir I'm who I am no I'm not
dead because I'm not that you know I'm
just a regular working actor you know so
I understand I mean
I had a woman tell me years ago when I
first got into business
she said yes I saw you uh in that uh
little thing you did I'm I'm surprised
that you were able to do that I'm like
uh a bigger pardon
she says well I uh I had a scholarship
in New York with Alvin Ailey which is
top Dance Company
you know I said oh yeah that's great she
says so if I couldn't make it what makes
you think you could make it
yeah she said that to me now I was at a
point where I was new in the business
and I was like oh okay
and you know it I still remember that
you know and I'm like oh and I'm sure
that woman has seen me over the years
you know she might be seeing you now she
might
and uh my first agent I got
in Detroit
she handed me a script
she says read this so it was a Kentucky
Fried Chicken commercial or whatever and
you know I had no real experience as far
as an actor like that so I read it she
says you have a great look oh beautiful
smile you really personality is great
but you'll never do voice over work
and I said oh okay and I was like
first of all I'm like voice over work
basically what's that
and and once it was explained to me I
said oh okay
so I'm like well why won't I be doing
that that's what I thought to myself
so how fate and how God and everything
works I moved into an apartment building
where one of the guys that lived in the
building was a recording engineer at us
at a studio
and I was in the laundry room one day
and he came in with his laundry and we
got to talking he says uh yeah Gerald
said that you uh you're into the acting
thing I said well I'm just starting out
in it he says oh do you do voice over I
says no uh my agent told me that I
probably wouldn't be able to do that he
says why not
so he says let me put a load of clothes
on come up to my come up to my apartment
go to his apartment
got a studio
he started teaching me how to do voice
over
so when I left Detroit and moved to
Chicago I had my first little demo tape
the agents heard it says this is pretty
good
now I had to gain more experience as I
went along
but that's how I got into that because
somehow you know God the the voiceover
gods were like how dare her say he she
he will never do that we determine this
you know so it just fell into place you
know I've been doing voiceovers ever
since matter of fact I got to go and do
something later I got to do some
auditions you know I get three or four a
day which is a lot of auditions voice
over auditions you get three or four a
day minimum
and I mean it's hard work to get but
it's very lucrative in fact I just did
two last actual jobs last week so but
you know that's how it is you know so
it's the business is crazy like that you
know people tell you stuff and then you
know your agents will say okay hey I
can't do this you can't do this you
can't do that and you're like oh
nobody likes to have somebody tell them
what they can do especially if they
haven't never done it before or haven't
tried it it's like okay
because at that point you know all of
the voiceover actors were still sounding
like this you know those commercials
back then now they don't want that and
since the pandemic
they want real
they want real if you notice the
commercials and everything and the voice
over stuff it's like people talking you
know during the pandemic it was really
rough for me and and I think I I was
able to you know go and get everything
taken care of and my medication is okay
as opposed to years ago
Tylenol medication the medicine that
will help you get over your headache you
remember years ago it's like it's all
changed so they want real people so I
was a re I was one of the first of the
real people
voice over people I was wondering I was
one of the first black guys to be a real
person in a in a voiceover audition or
in a job I was one of the first ones
well you could do both though that you
could do yeah the the the oh yeah stage
voice well sometimes I mean like like
yesterday last night as a matter of fact
when I got home I had to do one for uh I
forgot what
um
I'm not supposed to say the products
I've been nut but I had to be like um
new Don Pardo
here we go you know that whole thing new
on The Price is Right that kind of thing
I can do that stuff you know but you
don't do a lot of that stuff and then
they tend to go with those regular guys
that do that you know and most of us are
like I mean I have friends say I didn't
get that I said well they went with the
real person for that I mean you know the
real guy from you know uh Price is Right
or whatever you know it's no problem
with that you said okay but when it's
like regular stuff that's us you know I
tend to get people wanting me to do um
James Earl Jones we're looking for a
James Earl Jones type we're looking for
Ving Rhames you know who does uh uh
Arby's you we've got the meats and you
know they'll say we're looking for
something like that and I noticed that
whenever I try to sound like those
people I don't get that stuff so lately
what I've been doing is I've been saying
this is good for the voiceover lady I've
been saying you know what I'm gonna
sound like me
so instead of Arby's you like Arby's hey
great you know come get a burger I mean
whatever I booked those because you be
yourself you're not trying to sound like
Morgan Freeman no worries Morgan Freeman
you know I get all that kind of stuff
and I and I finally understood that
of course they don't want that actual
sound they want that kind of flavor you
know they want that kind of persona or
whatever so that's what you kind of get
into after a while but this is a lot of
like a lot of stuff like that you don't
learn in school you don't learn this
stuff in school you got to learn it out
here you got to learn it out here in the
real world and where people come out of
college and out of school and they say
oh well I'm going to do this then they
get out here and like wow
because there are people out here been
doing this a long time
and they're not going anywhere